I'm still on the floor, living but I know that it is just my own.。
Hello，大家好，我是Marc。
今天又来给大家讲商业故事了。
Ready? Go!。
那今天讲个什么故事呢？
就是现在全球人民都在关注的世界盃。
如果大家小伙伴知道的话，
就是这一届2026年的世界盃还是比较特殊的。
因为从1982年开始的世界盃，
总共就是24只球队，52场比赛。
1998年开始，球队数量上升到了32只，
共计64场比赛。
但是这一届世界盃，
总共有48只球队参赛，
比赛数量达到了104场，
是历史上规模最大的一届世界盃。
同时，这一届世界盃也是第一次有三个国家联合举办，
美国、加拿大和墨西哥、美加摩。
上一次联合举办是在24年前的2002年，
由韩国和日本两国举办的，
但当时效果其实并不好，
这个两国联合办例就说明这可能有更多的协调跟沟通成本，
更多的利益分配，更多的这种政治博弈。
所以在2002年之后，
世界盃曾经一度采取不鼓励联合申办的态度。
但是在这一届2020年，
竟然又是三个国家联合举办。
诶，闻到这个浓浓的金钱的气息了吗？
所以啊，
这个104场赛事要在三个国家进行，
可想而知，
这背后带动的效益，
旅游、消费、提占经济等等等等。
不过实际上，
世界盃最直接、最核心、最赚钱的商业收入，
大部分都不归举办国所有，
反倒属于一个总部位于瑞士、苏利市的组织，
也就是非法国际组联。
那么按照这一届世界盃的四年的周期来看，
就是从2023年到2026年，
非法的预计收入在130亿美元，
将近千亿人民币远超很多上市公司四年的收入。
就用我们之前的寺庙经济跟小短距市场做对比，
这两个行业整体在中国也才刚刚迈入千亿大关。
而非法凭一己之力，
在一个世界盃的周期就能和这两个行业比较了。
但很有意思的是，
世界盃的参赛球员不是非法培养的，
是国家或者说俱乐部培养的。
世界盃的比赛场地也不是非法花钱建设的，
是企业或者国家修建的，
甚至很多时候连举办世界盃的国家。
自己都要承担大量的成本，
比如说翻新地铁，搞基建，对不对？
但世界盃最赚钱的那部分收入，
却属于非法。
更有意思的是，
非法甚至不是一家企业，
而是一个非引力性的组织。
我们在寺庙经济当中也提到过，
非引力性组织这个概念，
它是一种类似于公司的组织形态，
但是并不是以引力为目标运营的。
所以问题就来了，
一个总部在瑞士的非引力组织，
为什么能够拥有世界盃呢？
非法它到底卖的是啥？
转播权为什么能卖出几十亿？
赞助商为什么愿意花天价。
买一个官方合作伙伴的身份？
为什么越来越多的观众。
反倒这一届的门票费用越来越贵了？
而世界盃创造出来的这些钱，
最终又留下了哪里呢？
今天这期节目，
我们就来拆解拆解世界盃背后的。
这门百亿美元生意。
我们先从非法最核心的。
这些商业模式说去，
看看这130亿美元，
到底都是从哪来的？
那最大头的，
大家可能也比较熟悉的，
当然就是转播权了，
叫做media right。
在2023年到2026年这一周期当中，
收入占比达到40%，
也就是转播权卖出去了。
50亿美元左右。
什么是转播权？
说白了，
我们之所以能在电视上面，
手机上面，
平板上面看到世界盃，
本质上呢，
是因为非法
把播放世界盃的权力卖给了。
电视台，
流媒体平台，
和各种媒体机构。
这也是非法最稳定，
平手的一门生意，
妥妥的一个现金牛的业务。
那么从商业链条上来说，
非法会组织全球统一的。
赛事的拍摄，
跟信号的制作，
投入拍摄设备，
请专业的团队负责。
现场的这种慢动作回放，
航拍镜头，
数据画面，
等等等等，
然后通过统一的信号，
发给了全世界
买了转播权的电视台，
跟流媒体平台。
虽然听起来很简单，
但实际上，
这个转播权，
可不是一个单一的产品，
而是一个复杂的
打包的产品，
里面包含了直播的权利，
重播的权利，
还有什么点播的权利，
一些不在直播当中的。
这种精彩积极，
等等等等，
内容的播放权。
那当然，
一般来说，
肯定还是直播的信力最大，
谁要看重播，对不对？
但是,
它既然是一个打包产品的概念，
那么非法，
当然也会物尽其用了，
它搞出了不同的，
你想象得到，
想象不到的，
这种排列组合的套餐，
比如说，
一个平台它能拆，
针对于传统电视台，
有传统电视台的
转播权套餐，
针对线上平台，
也有线上平台的套餐，
这两个，
是可以分开售卖的，
还有,
赛事其实也是能拆套餐的，
不知道大家知不知道，
你可以买104场赛事的，
全部转播权，
当然呢，
哎,
如果你没那么多钱，
我们也可以谈一谈嘛，
是不是可以直卖，
其中64场赛事的转播权，
甚至甚至，
直卖1-1之后的转播权，
都可以，
不仅如此，
甚至连语言也可以拆，
比如在美国，
Fox,
福克斯电视台，
买的是世界杯的英语转播权，
NBC旗下的电视台，
买的是西班牙语的转播权，
所以你看，
这个转播权，
它并不是一个，
统治化的产品，
而是一个，
高度定制化的产品，
非法,
把不同的，
这种,
转播权里面的权益，
排列组合，
变成一个个套餐，
和一个个国家，
一个个电视台，
分别去谈，
更有意思的是啥呢？
这个转播权，
到底该怎么定价呢？
到底该卖多少钱呢？
它其实，
是看人下菜叠大，
是没有一个统一标准的，
那非法，
长期以来的策略，
就是,
分区域，
分对象，
分别去谈判，
分别去定价，
分区这件事情，
当然很合理嘛，
比如说，
在韩国播放，
那当然要跟韩国的电视台，
韩国的主要的流媒体，
去谈卖卖，
在美国播放，
那你就要和Fox，
NBC去谈,
但是,
即便是一模一样的淘残，
一模一样的权益，
针对不同的对象，
价格,
也可以是完全不一样的，
这个呢，
在商业上，
就叫做价格歧视，
就即便它是同样的产品，
根据不同市场的支付议院，
会卖出去不同的价格，
你看,
航空公司不就是
这么卖机票的嘛，
同一趟航班，
你提前3个月
买的经济仓，
可能只要800块钱，
临时卖的经济仓，
可能要1500，
而起飞前24小时，
要买的经济仓的特价票，
可能只要300块钱，
所以,
跟这个，
跟这个viva卖转播权的逻辑，
是一模一样的，
就同一个世界盃，
不同的市场，
就是不同的价格，
就我们来先看看，
最贵的市场之一，
美国,
我们刚刚说的Fox，
拿到了2026届世界盃，
在美国的英语转播权，
花了将近4.8亿美元，
NBC拿到了西班牙语的转播权，
差不多花了4.6亿美元，
那这两家公司，
是早在2017年，
就已经确定了，
十年前，
他们就买下了，
这一届世界盃的转播权，
你看,
可以谈得多早，
那很多人呢，
会说这个Fox，
跟NBC其实是转了，
因为当时，
在2017年,
他们拿下转播权的时候，
viva并没有决定，
把赛事扩充到104厂，
还是原来的，
这个64厂的这么一个水平，
直到2013年，
viva才做出这么一个决定，
那你看，
花了64厂的钱，
看了104厂的比赛，
那Fox跟NBC,。
可不是乐泛天了吗？
那这么看，
确实是，
但是,
如果我们再看看，
viva卖给,
印度的转播权价格，
可能就不会这么说了，
不像是Fox，
和NBC,
早早的就锁定了，
印度呢，
是直到2026年的6月1日，
是世界盃第一场赛事的10天前，
才和viva最终敲定下来，
viva呢,
以6千万美元的第一价，
将转播权，
卖给了印度的最大的媒体集团，
Z,
包含了这个电视，
跟刘媒体的转播权，
那你想想，
美国一个语言版本，
就要将近收5亿，
印度全国市场，
才6千万美元，
8倍的这个价差，
这就是我们说的价格歧视，
一模一样的产品，
同一个世界盃，
但是在不同的市场，
就是不同的价格，
但是为什么会这个样子呢？
Fox和NBC是傻子吗？
会允许被这么歧视吗？
那当然可以，
只要他们能算得过来账，
就不管是电视台，
还是刘媒体，
他们买到的，
虽然是世界盃的这个转播权，
但本质上，
买到的是世界盃转播权，
可以带来的收益呀，
比如说像是Fox，
可能美国队的比赛，
开幕式呢，
他确实会放在自己的。
免费频道播放，
但是在这个比赛前的直播间，
中场休息的直播间，
甚至在后的评论节目，
他都可以插入广告呀，
只要找到广告商，
就能靠着短短几十秒赚钱，
而非美国队的小组赛，
他可以放在自己的付费频道，
可以放在自己的这个。
线上app上面，
必须要花钱订阅才能看，
又能赚一波订阅费用，
而即便在付费频道，
中间也是可以插入广告的呀，
咱们的这个爱忧腾对吧，
爱奇义忧酷腾讯，
也都是这么干的嘛，
而且,
如果观众错过了直播，
没关系，
我们还可以单独卖，
点播回看的这种权益，
有太多的形式，
可以带来收益了，
但当然，
每一个电视台和平台，
能够变现的能力都不同，
所以,
转播权对于他们来说，
价值也不一样，
要算得过来账，
6000万也好，
4.8也好,
都是合理的价格，
或者说，
统一价格标准，
不存在价格歧视，
可能才是不合理的一件事情。
而另外一个有意思的是呢，
不仅仅是，
印度花了6000万美元，
买下世界杯的转播权，
如果大家有看到新闻的话，
就是之前有铺天盖地的希莱，
这个,
我们的中央广播电视总台，
可以理解，
就是央视的这个上级机构，
最终,
也花了6000万美元，
就买下了世界杯的转播权。
2016年年初的时候，
匪法是打算以2.5亿美元，
左右的价格，
售卖出来的，
匪法呢，
提出这个价格，
也是有些底气的，
因为人家也会做，
数据分析跟统计嘛，
他们发现说，
就是2022年，
卡塔尔世界杯那一届的时候，
电视观众里面，
有将近20%是中国的观众，
那么中国呢，
线上社交媒体的讨论度呢，
也更是达到了50%，
那么当然，
要卖高价了，
对不对，
这么多人看，
能产生的收益，
但是结果呢，
咱们广播总台，
并没有接招啊，
双方就一路谈到了，
2016年5月份，
也并没有谈论，
为此呢，
匪法的秘书长，
还在5月中旬，
亲自访问北京，
那最终呢，
才谈下来，
而且,
咱们的广播总台，
拿到的不仅仅是，
转播权，
还包含了，
再授权的权利，
啥意思，
也就是，
可以把，
转播权，
授权给，
国内其他的媒体集团，
同步直播，
那很多小伙伴会问了，
说,
为什么六千万价格，
这么便宜呢，
匪法也愿意卖，
那这就是，
谈价格中，
双方博弈的结果，
从表面上来看，
匪法这一届的世界杯，
和中国的谈判，
确实是有点吃亏的，
首先,
有时差问题，
那,
每家墨世界杯的比赛时间呢，
对中国观众非常不友好，
很多比赛，
是在凌晨进行的，
这,
会大幅，
降低收视率，
那你收视率低了，
自然,
愿意付出的价格，
就少了嘛，对不对，
你转播权的价格，
也没有办法，
轰抬得太高了，
那第二呢，
其实我是看到，
很多媒体有说，
说有部分的原因，
是因为世界杯，
也没有中国队，
因为你们幻想一下嘛，
对不对，
就是有中国队的世界杯决赛，
和没有中国队的世界杯决赛，
哪个有更多中国人看，
咱就别说决赛了，
就是说小组赛，
对吧,
那当然，
这个理由呢，
我不太扮硬，
因为历史上，
有中国队的世界杯，
有且只有一季，
但不管如何吧，
就在这两点上面，
确实明面上，
非法在谈判上不占优势，
但如果从更深层次来看，
非法呢，
确实也受到了一些制约，
说白了，
中国尤其只会有这么一个买家，
广播总台，
肯定是拥有独家买端权的，
非法是不太可能，
绕过广播总台，
和其他媒体机构，
私自去谈的，
那大家都懂嘛，
对不对，
那么当市场上，
只有这么一个买家的时候，
那这就是一个买房市场了，
对不对，
然后就会有人说，
非法难道不能干脆不卖吗？
还真的不能，
首先,
你世界杯的内容，
不管怎么样，
都是要制作出来的，
成本就那么多，
你能多卖一个，
就试一个，
你多卖一个，
就多赚一分钱，
为什么不卖呢？
其次,
要想想，
非法有多少中国赞助商，
这些中国赞助商，
难道仅仅只是给外国人看广告的吗？
当然不是，
那即便不论中国的赞助商，
就说可口可乐这个赞助商，
我花了这么多钱，
赞助世界杯，
最后你非法告诉我说，
世界杯不能在中国，
如此庞大人口基础的国家播放，
那非法也无法交代嘛，对不对？
所以,
最终的结果就是，
非法必须妥协，
以6000万元的价格，
卖给了我们的广播总台，
而讲到这里呢，
我也想稍微延伸一下，
小伙伴们可能也发现了，
其实这些世界杯，
我们不仅能在广播总台下面的央视，
跟央视的app上面看到世界杯，
还能在小红书，
跟咪咕视频上面看到，
这是为啥呢？
还记得我们前面说的吗？
广播总台，
非法那里买到的，
不仅仅是世界杯的转播权，
还包含了再收权的权利，
所以,
你能在小红书，
跟咪咕上面看到世界杯的直播，
也是因为广播总台，
把权利，
转卖给了小红书跟咪咕，
我看到一个业界的说法，
不保证，
据说小红书跟咪咕，
分别花了17人民币，
和10亿人民币，
从广播总台那边，
卖下再收权的权利，
那如果真是这样，
可真的就是赚大法了，
广播总台花了6000万美元，
也就是不到5亿人民币，
买下的转播权，
那转手一卖，
就是27个亿，
这一导手，
就是22个亿，
哎,
但有意思的是，
为什么小红书要花这么多钱，
17个亿买下世界杯的转播权呢？
当然,
肯定会带来广告收入，
这没啥好说的，
我们前面也提到过，
而除此之外，
可能还有一个更重要的原因，
就是小红书在面临，
用户增长的问题，
小红书现在有，
月货4亿的用户，
日货在1.5亿左右，
但是其中，
女性用户的占比，
超过70%,
所以,
购买世界杯转播权的这个动作，
或许是小红书，
为了吸引更多的男户性用户，
而采取的，
所以从这个角度上面看，
小红书买的，
可能不仅仅只是世界杯的转播权，
它买的，
可能也是上义男性用户的一个注意力，
那至于这笔账，
最后能不能算得过来吗？
我个人可能并不是太好，
大家也可以在评论区，
一些讨论讨论，
我在这儿呢，
就不过多地展开了，
毕竟我们这个，
主题还是viva，
咱们把镜头拉回viva，
那么说完了，
转播权，
咱们再看看另外一块肥肉，
广告赞助商的收入，
在这一个世界杯的周期当中，
viva的广告赞助收入，
预期在32亿美元，
占比达到25%，
但是当然，
就跟外卖平台，
滴滴航空公司的会员系统是一样的，
viva的这个世界杯的赞助商，
也是有分层分系统的，
不同的层级，
对应不同的价格，
那么viva的这种赞助商，
被设计成了一个，
三层的金字塔结构，
最上层的，
叫做pana合作伙单，
这一层买到了，
不只是世界杯，
而是viva整个体系的，
长期合作权，
包括世界杯，
市局杯，
女族赛事，
等等一系列，
viva旗下的核心赛事，
通常是打包合作的，
而且是全球范围内的这么一个合作，
那么,
这一层的特点是，
周期长，
覆盖广，
价格最高，
一个周期，
这些赞助商，
花一亿美元以上，
像是coca,
elidas,
visa这些,
都是viva长期的，
定期合作伙伴，
那么第二层，
叫做sponsor赞助商，
这一层，
更偏向是，
单一一个世界杯的合作，
可以理解为，
主要这些赞助商，
就是绑定了某一届的世界杯，
而不是整个viva的体系，
而这个单一绑定，
单次投入，
可能是在6500万美元，
到9500万美元之间，
像是我们之前讲过的百威，
包括咱们的猛牛，
都是sponsor级别的，
这种金主爸爸们，
再往下一层，
第三层，
叫做supporter支持者，
这些支持者，
一般来讲，
都是viva的，
在区域层面的一些合作，
比如说，
这一届在美加墨，
viva就和armbnb,。
在北美区域，
达成了合作，
那么当然，
这一级别的赞助费用，
就更少了，
差不多在，
1000万到2500万美元之间，
但是,
我们试想一下，
区域性的这种supporter，
以最便宜，
也要花1000万美元，
而全球性的合作，
最便宜，
也要从6500万美元起调，
高得要超过1亿，
这些赞助商，
花钱买的，
到底是个啥呢？
当然,
最直观的，
就是赛事广告的一个曝光了，
赛场的这些LED的围栏，
求门后方的广告位置，
转播画面的录出，
viva官网,
App的展示，
这些都是广告位的曝光，
那这么听起来，
是不是有点积累呢？
对吧?
赞助商爸爸们，
真的缺这些广告位吗？
可能还真的缺，
因为不管怎么样，
世界杯这个赛事，
本来就是有稀缺性的，
4年才有一次，
错过这一届就要再等4年，
而且,
全球能同时出达，
几十亿观看人次的IP，
只有这一个，
甚至比奥运会的观看人次，
还要高，
所以,
本身他们广告位的价值，
确实是比较高的，
那么其次呢，
赞助商们买到的，
还是viva世界杯，
赴予的一个官方身份，
如果这一届赞助商，
在这期间做广告，
是可以在广告上面，
放出世界杯赞助商，
世界杯合作伙伴，
这些特殊正式称号的，
以及他们所有的营销物料，
都可以带着，
viva世界杯的这个logo，
他们是有，
viva世界杯的官方背书的，
所以这个也很重要，
但是除此之外，
另外一个也很重要的是，
赞助商买到了一个，
排他权，
啥意思？
像是,
可欧可乐，
是属于第一层级，
潘娜层级的，
viva的合作伙伴，
所以,
百世可乐，
永远不可能，
成为viva的合作伙伴，
除非可可可乐不赞助了，
像是咱们的猛牛，
这是第二届赞助世界杯了，
属于第二层级的，
这种sponsor级别的赞助商，
所以,
viva也不可能，
接受一例的赞助，
除非猛牛不赞助，
那么这个就是排他权，
能够有viva世界杯，
官方盖出的赞助商，
一个行业里面，
尤其只能有一个，
但很有意思的是，
我们前面不是说，
小红书从广播总台，
购买世界杯的转播权吗？
就如果你现在打开小红书，
点到最上面，
世界杯的那个tab，
可以看到小红书，
和一例是有合作的，
那我们要知道，
这个其实是被允许的，
就,
viva是不禁止，
电视台跟这个平台，
在买了转播权之后，
在这个转播权的商业化过程当中，
引入其他同类的广告商的，
那只是这些广告商，
并不是viva官方盖出的而已，
所以呢，
也就是说，
猛牛能够出现在跟世界杯相关的，
各种画面当中，
也能被称之为世界杯的赞助商，
但是一例呢，
只能露出在小红书上面，
它也不能用世界杯赞助商的名字，
做宣传推广，
但不管怎么样吧，
对于这些在高度竞争的公司当中，
谁能拿下世界杯，
好像就是一种输融，
也是一种拍塌，
那么很有意思的是呢，
这几年，
越来越多的中国金主爸爸们，
成为了世界杯的，
第一层合作伙伴，
或者说第二层的，
这种赞助商级别，
但是2026年这一届，
猛牛联想和海信加在一起，
投入了3.2亿美元的赞助费用，
占到非法这一周期，
赞助费用了10%，
那么对于非法来说，
是非常可观的了，
而这些中国赞助商投资非法的世界杯，
也有着各自不同的目的，
最主要的一种目的，
是典型的这种出海类型的企业，
他们是想借着世界杯的这种全球性，
来宣传跟拓展自己的全球化业务，
像是这一届的赞助商海信，
是以家电消费品为主营业务的一家公司，
已经从2018年开始，
到现在已经赞助了三届的世界杯了，
那么在2018年，
第一次赞助世界杯之前，
它的海外业务占比在20%左右，
到了去年，
2025年,
海外业务的占比已经达到了50%，
那当然，
我们不能说，
仅仅是因为赞助世界杯，
就让它的海外业务腾飞了，
但是确实，
海信曾经多次提到，
世界杯赞助是战略级别的这么一个主腿，
所以不仅是海信，
比如说，
像是2018年赞助的Vivo，
因为它的海外业务占比，
也达到了50%，
那么这一届赞助的联想，
海外业务占比，
是达到65%左右，
那么这些企业的赞助，
其实都是在向世界宣传，
自己不仅仅只是一个中国品牌，
是一个中国企业，
而是一个全球性的这么一个企业，
那么聊到这里，
就有小板会说了，
猛牛为什么要赞助呢？
难道也有海外业务吗？
确实,
从事实的角度来讲，
猛牛也有小部分的海外业务，
主要还是在聚焦东南亚为主，
但是占比非常非常非常小，
大家也知道嘛，
猛牛至少现在，
绝对不是一个重心，
以海外业务为主的公司，
所以猛牛赞助的目的，
还是更偏重，
去影响中国的观众，
尤其是，
它目前基本上和伊利，
在国内是属于
装虎，装寡头的竞争格局嘛，
对不对，
所以它当然是希望，
通过世界费的倍数，
能让自己的品牌的信任度，
有进一步的提升，
但我们前面也提到了，
伊利很聪明，
对不对，
他虽然没有买到赞助商，
或说,
我猜测，
其实伊利根本也没有，
想要去买赞助商，
他选择蹭世界费的流量，
所以呢，
和小红书合作，
那我这几天，
刚好也和业内的小伙伴，
打听了一下，
说是伊利只花了，
2000万人民币，
就谈下这次合作，
相比于猛牛，
对吧,
我们说嘛，
猛牛这个层级的赞助商，
差不多是要花到，
6500万的美元，
才能够成为赞助商的，
所以,
哎,
高下立见，
对不对，
但anyway,。
就是,
虽然很多人会质疑，
投资世界费，
到底能不能带来，
那么直接的一个效应，
但是不管如何，
世界费的赞助商们，
真的就是，
每届排着队，
给非法送钱，
像是Edidas,。
从1970年开始，
就赞助世界费，
可可可乐，
从1978年开始，
Visa,
从2007年开始，
基本上，
都是没有断过档的，
那么对于非法来说，
是一个，
稳定的，
可预期的一个，
庞大收入了，
好,
那么我们说完了，
转播权跟，
赞助商的这个收入，
另外一个很大头的，
其实就是，
世界费的，
门票相关收入了，
那么在2023年，
到2026年的这个周期下面，
门票相关收入，
预计在36亿美元，
占所有收入的28%，
比起广告商，
赞助收入，
还要高，
不过呢，
这个我们也要，
稍微解释清楚一下，
门票相关收入当中，
一半是来自于，
普通门票的收买，
剩下的一半，
卖的是hospitality,。
啥意思，
说白了，
就是个VIP套餐，
主要呢，
是收买给企业，
以及高端客户的，
那么这个VIP套餐，
最便宜的单场，
就要2000-5000美元了，
包括可能有一些，
贵宾休息室，
酒水,
自助餐，
转属座位等等，
那么贵的价格，
可能就是要，
达到上万美元，
到几十万美元，
不等了，
甚至有VIP的包乡，
来去观看比赛，
所以,
虽然从收入的角度来讲，
hospitality的收入,。
跟普通门票收入，
是五五开，
但是如果真正，
从利润的角度来讲，
可想而知嘛，
就这个VIP套餐，
hospitality,。
才是,
非法的利润，
主要来源，
那当然，
除了这三大收入以外呢，
非法,
还有一小部分的收入，
来自于授权，
比如说，
像是非法足球的游戏，
然后呢，
再比如说，
有一些球衣，
使用了非法世界背的logo，
还有球星卡等等，
那么像是今年乐高，
也推出了非常多，
和非法联名合作的产品，
这些产品，
都是来自于，
非法的授权的，
说白了，
就是要花钱，
买世界背这个IP，
但整体来说呢，
授权收入占比并不大，
核心的，
还是我们说的，
转播权，
广告赞助，
跟门票相关收入，
而,
如果我们再进一步，
看看非法这几年的发展，
就会发现说，
哎呀,
收入真的是，
越转越多了，
2015年,
到2018年,
俄罗斯世界背的这个周期，
非法的整体收入，
是在64亿美元左右，
那么到了2019年，
到2022年,
卡塔尔世界背的这个周期，
非法世界背的收入，
达到了76亿美元，
而到了这一届，
非法预计，
他们的收入，
可以达到130亿美元，
比起上一届，
基本上，
是翻了近两倍左右，
这说明什么？
这说明，
非法这门世界背，
商业化的生意，
玩的是越来越，
炉火纯净，
越来越激进了，
怎么说呢？
我们来看一看，
那最直观的，
我们大家都知道，
就是规模的提升嘛，
赛事扩军，
这一届的世界背，
从32支球队，
扩充到了48支球队，
从64场比赛，
扩充到了104场比赛，
比赛增加了63%，
这就意味着，
非法有更多的内容，
可以卖给电视台，
跟平台了嘛，
对不对，
这就意味着，
赞助商有更多的露出了，
这也意味着，
可以卖出去，
卖出去更多的门票，
跟套餐了，
虽然有市场机构分析，
说2026年,
世界背的单场的收入价值，
实际上下降了，
这个也很好理解嘛，
因为你比赛太多了，
你的价值就相对被稀释了，
观众的注意力是有限的，
也不是说，
每一场比赛，
都一定有大批量的观众观看，
尤其是一些，
名气比较差，
比较冷门的球队，
那非法的算盘是，
我只要总量赢了就可以嘛，
对不对，
即便单场收入下降，
那么104场的总收入，
如果还是超过64场，
那我就搞，
这就是规模带来的，
新的收入增长。
而如果说赛事扩军，
是最直观的，
对于量的增长手段，
那么非法第二个手段，
是门票价格的突破，
但这个手段呢，
就吃相有点难看了，
只是从商业的角度来说，
还是挺合理的，
怎么说呢？
今年,
非法世界背，
首次推出的动态定价模式，
啥意思？
原来,
世界背的门票价格其实是固定的，
也就是说，
如果我买小组赛，
最便宜的作为，
就是60块钱，
美金一张，
不管是冷门的球队，
还是热门球队的小组赛，
那么当然，
越往后，
你四分之一，
你决赛，
你票价就会越高，
但不管怎么样，
这些票价，
其实都是提前，
设置好的一个固定价格，
但今年不一样了，
世界背采用了动态定价模式，
它会考虑热门赛事，
会考虑有多少人抽钱来买票，
比赛在哪个城市进行，
是在哪个阶段放票等等的综合因素，
来去给每一场赛事做动态定价，
像是现在已经完成的比赛，
我稍微搜了一下，
比如东道主美国队的小组赛，
一张门票已经突破上千美元了，
那么决赛票的价格，
现在还不知道是谁，
但是决赛票的价格，
官方的已经定在了，
4千块钱美元往上了，
4千块钱是最便宜的票，对吧，
那么这些定价，
就是完全基于市场供需关系，
非常商业化的定价机制了，
玩的非常流，
而除此之外，
FIFA在票价上面，
还找到了一个吃相更难看的赚钱方法，
哎，就是什么呢，
二手交易，
就原来，
如果你买了一张世界杯的门票，
但是不想去了，
FIFA是有一个官方的。
二手转售平台的，
这个转售是按照你出使，
购入价格来去转售的，
比如说你花了60美元买这张票，
不想去了，
那转售出去也是60美元，
你能收到60美元，
对方呢，
也是花60美元来买这张票的，
这是官方的平台嘛，
但当然，
民间呢，
也有一些非官方的二手交易平台，
或者说专门的这个黄牛，
那非官方的交易，
就是完全看市场，
对吧,
可能你花60美元买的票，
转售出去就是100美元，
而长久以来呢，
FIFA肯定是不鼓励黄牛的，
因为黄牛赚的钱，
跟FIFA没有半毛钱关系，
还绕断了市场，
但是呢，
一直也没有什么有效的手段，
能够打击黄牛，
那咋办？
好，既然打击不了黄牛，
那就让黄牛帮我赚钱吧，
所以,
FIFA今年出来了一个新招，
在FIFA自己的官方转售平台，
开始允许观众，
以自己想要定义的价格，
转售卖出去，
已经购买的文票了，
原来你花60块钱买的票，
在官方平台只能用60块钱卖出去，
现在你可以随意自己定，
你想要定1000块钱都没有人管你，
只要有人卖，
那FIFA又有什么利益驱动做这件事情呢？
就是我说的实际上很难看，
因为这一次，
FIFA会针对买卖双方，
各自收取15%的服务费，
如果成交价，
真的是1000美元一张票，
卖方只能收到8850块钱，
对吧,
那么卖方则要花1150块钱，
这中间的300美元，
FIFA就吃掉了，
这基本上就是领本万利，
因为这个官方转售平台早就有了，
所以不需要重新搭建，
所以你看，
通过这种动态定价，
跟转售机制两件事情，
FIFA这一届的门票，
跟VIP套餐收入，
是上一届的四倍，
太聪明，太聪明了，
那最后呢，
除了赛事扩军，
跟这个价格的调整，
在这一届世界盃当中，
我还有一个非常有意思的观察，
我感觉呢，
就我个人感觉，
这也是FIFA新的一次，
商业化尝试，
那这啥东西呢？
就长久以来，
我们前面也提到了嘛，
就FIFA针对的这个服务对象，
比较传统，
无非是像这个视频平台，
或者说电视台，
售卖转播权，
像有钱的金主爸爸们，
品牌,
就是售卖广告赞助权，
以及像观众售卖门票，
跟VIP套餐，
那这中间还少了点啥吗？
如果我们考虑到
现如今的互联网生态，
跟内容生态，
那当然，
就还有内容创作平台，
跟内容创作者，
这些非常重要的角色了，
FIFA呢,
也很敏锐的意识到了这一点，
所以今年，
FIFA宣布与TikTok,。
达成了正式的一个合作，
我们说的是这个国际的TikTok，
不是国内抖音，
那这一次合作，
具体而言，
并不是说TikTok，
从FIFA那边拿到了。
世界盃的转播权，
它也是不能完整的播放比赛的，
但是,
FIFA允许比赛的精彩片段，
仅仅采访等等的，
这一系列花絮的东西，
在TikTok上面传播，
并进行二创，
不仅如此，
在这次合作当中，
FIFA和TikTok还搞出了一个。
Creator Correspondence计划,。
内容创作者计划，
它选拔了30位全球的创作者，
给他们前所未有的一个。
幕后采访权限，
包括参加新闻发布会，
包括背后去后采，
训练的session，
球员的采访，
就已经把这些创作者们。
当做记者来处理了，
虽然这些创作者产生出来的。
原生内容，
只能够在TikTok上面发布，
但是FIFA是允许这些创作者。
利用这些内容，
进行变现的，
FIFA也不抽成，
这就让我有两个很有意思的假说了，
那么其中一个就是，
这种尝试，
我觉得是真的很有可能。
能够拓宽FIFA收入的边界的，
就我们前面也说了，
虽然FIFA有官方的这种。
赞助商体系，
但是动辄几千万美元，
上亿美元的赞助费用，
不可能是所有品牌。
都能拿得出来的，
对吧,
除外FIFA也很难说。
一个个接触非常小的。
这种只有一点点钱的赞助商，
但是内容创作者
就可以接触到更多更小的。
分散的品牌方了，
那这些品牌方可能预算有限，
它不可能成为FIFA的。
这种顶级赞助商，
但是,
它也可以拿出一条。
视频内容的广告赞助费，
这它是拿得出来的，
那么虽然现在FIFA。
只官方盖出了
30个内容创作者，
也不抽成，
但是一旦这个商业链路跑通，
就很有机会了，
所以我觉得这个尝试。
是一个模式链路，
是否能跑通的测试，
当然,
也有很多二创的很有意思的内容，
也同时能够帮助FIFA。
去更好的宣传它的世界备，
这是我的第一个假说，
就是说，
他们做这件事情，
是能够拓宽FIFA。
未来的收入边界的，
那么其次，
我还有另外一个假说，
这个假说，
就连接回到了FIFA。
采取动态票价，
为什么票价
会这么贵的，
这个角度，
我猜测，
可能票价被炒戈的原因之一，
是有更多的内容创作者，
去现场观看，
并通过内容创作获利，
当然,
我们说的内容创作者，
不是FIFA官方盖出的那三十个，
而是普通大众的，
普通的内容创作者，
这些KOL,
理论上，
他们拍摄的内容，
是有可能倾全的，
我们要知道，
从法律上来说，
就一个KOL，
你可以拍自己的Vlog，
你可以在比赛前，
拍自己的OTDE，
对吧,
你可以拍在这个，
赛场等待的画面，
比赛结束后的画面，
比赛中，
你怼着自己拍的，
如追action的画面，
这些法律上是合法的，
但是,
如果你拍摄，
现场比赛中的画面，
没有获得FIFA的授权，
那是违法的，
但是,
一方面，
FIFA确实也很难抓，
我怎么可能，
一个个视频，
一个个视频去看，
看看人家到底有没有，
露出现场的比赛画面，
那么另外呢，
就即便这些KOL内容创作者，
他不拍比赛中的画面，
只拍vlog,
只拍比赛结束的画面，
只怼着自己的脸拍，
那么这些内容，
在一定程度上，
也是有流量的，
所以内容创作者，
依然有利可图，
那么既然有利可图，
他们就可能，
更愿意花重金去现场，
那么,
自然,
这个票价，
就会被炒高了，
但不管如何，
不管是，
FIFA官方认证的，
内容创作者，
还是民间的，
理论上，
都能从中获利，
记住,
意味着，
请,
可能能跑通，
说不定下一届世界杯，
我们就能够，
见到FIFA新的，
变现模式了，
所以,
总的来说，
大家看吧，
这就是为什么，
上一届世界杯周期，
FIFA的收入，
在75亿美元左右，
这一届，
预计可以达到，
130亿美元，
赛事扩充，
市场花了动态价格，
无疑就是最大的推手，
那么新的内容，
创作者计划，
虽然未必对，
这一周期的收入，
有较大影响，
但一定，
不管是短期，
还是长期，
都能看出，
FIFA的商业化思维，
而说到这里，
我们只说了收入，
对吧,
这130亿,
只是FIFA的收入而已，
那么FIFA最后，
到底能赚多少钱呢？
或者换个更准确的问题，
这130亿美元，
到底最后都去哪儿了呢？
这就很有意思了，
因为正如我们，
开头所说，
FIFA,
实际上，
是一个非引力组织，
啥意思？
这个其实，
让我们在，
提到过这个概念，
FIFA,
是1904年,
在巴黎城里，
1932年,
把总部签到了瑞士，
苏利士，
已经存在122年了，
那么在瑞士的法律体系下，
FIFA,
是一个非引力协会，
就很类似于，
我们中国的，
这种非引力组织，
它是由全球211个，
会员协会，
共同组成的，
像是中国组邪，
阿根廷组邪，
德国组邪，
等等,
但,
非引力组织这个概念，
我们要先搞清楚，
非引力，
不等于不引力，
非引力组织，
不是不能赚钱的，
它完全可以赚钱，
甚至可以赚很多的钱，
法律上，
禁止的，
不是引力这件事情，
而是利润分配，
什么意思，
举个简单的例子，
比如你是一家公司的股东，
你一个公司收入有100万，
那你扣除的成本，
50万,
剩下50万，
是可以分给股东的，
这就是分红嘛，
那当然，
你也可以选择部分，
如果股东都同意，
公司可以拿这50万，
投资回公司，
在明年继续扩大规模，
因为说不定明年，
就可以赚300万了，
那股东可以分这300万，
那当然，
股东依然可以选择部分，
这呢,
是公司的逻辑，
但是,
非引力组织赚取的收入，
在扣除成本后，
剩下的钱，
是不能用于分配的，
非引力组织，
也没有股东这个概念，
剩下的钱，
只能用于，
这个非引力组织，
章程规定的用途，
比如说，
一个工艺基金会，
可以募捐，
扣除募捐活动成本，
扣除商品成本，
剩下的钱，
只能用于工艺事业，
再比如说，
像是四庙经济那一期，
我们也说了，
一家四庙，
可以售卖商品，
可以售香火钱，
但是扣除成本之后，
剩下的钱，
只能用于，
四庙的一个修善，
以及宗教活动，
等等,
所以,
非法也是一样的，
虽然非法，
在这一届世界被周期当中，
预计能拿到
130亿的收入，
但实际上，
这笔钱，
一分钱，
都不能用于分后，
那么问题就来了，
既然没有人能分，
这130亿美元，
总得有个去除吧，
我们简单来拆分一下，
最大头的去除，
其实是赛事运营，
competition and event,。
这一周期，
所有赛事的运营相关投入，
大概是76亿美元，
占所有支出的60%左右，
这个时候，
小伙伴会问了，
世界背对这个赛场，
又不是非法修建的，
对吧,
很多成本，
不是主办国承担的吗？
哪来这么多运营成本呢？
确实主办国，
会承担很多成本，
像是2022年的时候，
卡塔二世界背，
政府花了2200亿美元，
不过这里面有2000亿美元，
是花在了，
地铁公路交通，
等等的基础设施上面，
跟赛事没有直接关系，
剩下200美元，
是跟赛事直接相关的，
像是修建球场，
公共安防运营之类的，
而这一届，
美加摩世界背，
三个国家加起来，
暂时预计，
会花费150亿美元，
所以很多人会说，
美加摩三国，
这一届还是很划算的，
因为赛事扩军了，
但花费更少了，
不过anyway,。
回到非法的赛事运营成本，
虽然主办国承担了，
很多基建，
球场,
城市配套，
外围安保的成本，
但是和世界背赛事，
直接运转，
相关的很多成本，
还是非法承担的，
我随便举一些例子，
比如说，
像是世界背的奖金，
对吧,
就不仅仅是，
才有奖金的，
全部球队都是有奖金的，
这全是非法拿的，
预计,
今年总奖金池，
会在6.6亿美元，
再比如说，
像是票物成本，
大家可能会说，
你卖票还要啥成本，
不就是一张电子票吗？
其实不是的，
非法的票物系统，
本身就是一套大系统，
我们前面说的那些，
抽签预约的系统，
动态定价，
转收平台，
支付系统，
这些所有的系统，
都会产生成本的，
再比如说，
球队的服务，
训练场地，
接待安排，
等等等等的事项，
不是说，
球队自己，
随便定个酒店就来了，
这些成本，
非法也要承担，
当然,
在赛事过程当中，
裁判,
VAR,
场内的保安，
赛事工作人员的培训，
这些都要钱，
今年的裁判，
我不知道大家有没有注意，
不是还会配戴，
那个body camera,。
摄像机，
这些其实，
也都属于，
非法为了，
赛事运营，
跟转播体验，
投入的钱，
虽然我们说，
但是跟赛事，
最直接相关的运营成本，
其实都是非法出的，
这也就成为了，
它最大头的，
现金之处，
那么,
除此之外呢，
非法毕竟是一个组织嘛，
它不是一个，
只有在世界杯期间，
才会临时出现的团队，
那平时的非法，
也要养自己，
它有总部，
有员工，
也要有法务，
有财务，
有IT系统，
有审计，
有各种委员会，
它还有代表大会，
也有全球范围内的，
这种日常运营，
它还有将近9亿美元的，
组织行政成本，
在所有支出的7%左右，
那这一部分呢，
看起来，
占比不算大，
但是也一直被外界购并啊，
比如说，
像是非法的主席，
Gianni Infantino,。
他的薪资，
虽然披露口径，
不是那么直观，
但是外界预估，
他一年的薪资，
在300万美元，
到400万美元之间，
这还没加上，
各主纲的福利根奖金，
而相比之下，
国际奥委会主席，
巴赫的年薪，
大概是25万欧元，
联合股秘书传，
古特雷斯的年薪，
大概是22万美元，
你想想这个差距，
是非常非常大的，
所以,
就你会发现，
就非法，
虽然不是一家公司，
但是它的组织机器，
一点都不小，
这些成本，
那anyway,。
刨除了这个赛事运营，
跟组织行政，
上面的一些，
杂七杂八的支出，
其实,
在这130亿当中，
还剩下将近30%的钱，
那这些钱，
非法还能拿来干嘛呢？
这就要说回到，
我们说的，
非法的本质了，
一个非盈利组织，
这些剩下来，
扣除成本之后的钱，
只能用于，
这个非盈利组织，
章程规定的用途，
而在非法章程的，
第一章当中，
就有提到，
非法的宗旨，
包括了，
促进足球运动的发展，
以及在全球推广足球，
等等等等，
所以对非法来说，
这是一种，
必须完成的使命，
所以这些剩下的钱，
全部花在了，
足球发展，
和教育上面，
那为此呢，
非法推出了一个，
非法forward program,。
国际足连向前发展计划，
每年呢，
会拨款，
给到211个，
协会成员，
帮助他们，
发展足球实验，
那这个钱呢，
这些协会成员呢，
可以用于，
各种各样的，
和足球发展，
相关的思想上面，
比如说，
裁判跟教练的培训，
办国内的联赛，
青少年联赛，
女足联赛，
修建球场，
搞训练基地，
足球学校，
等等等等，
那当然啊，
这个拨款呢，
不是随便给的，
不是非法说，
哎，中国足协，
这里有笔钱，
拿去花吧，
就非法呢，
会和每一个这个，
协会成员，
都制定一个发展协议，
就像是，
我们的十四五规划，
十五规划，
里面会约定，
未来的四年，
要做什么项目，
我的KPI是啥，
钱怎么花，
怎么验收，
这些,
是协会成员，
和非法一起制定的，
那么,
每个协会成员的协议，
他们的足球发展，
情况是不一样的，
那么在有了协议之后呢，
协会成员呢，
比如说，
像是中国足协，
就要递交详细的，
proposal方案,。
就跟在公司做项目是一样的，
要说明预算是多少，
我的时间限制怎么样的，
具体执行计划是什么，
项目怎么落地，
有了方案，
要递交，
非法审批，
必须要通过审批，
才会拨款，
那这个拨款，
也不是一笔给你的，
要按周期来，
项目落地的期间，
会有非常完整的一些，
监督报告跟控制机制，
验收机制，
看看验收有没有通过，
如果没有通过，
会要求你整盖，
如果还不行，
那就停止拨款，
所以整体来看，
这也不是一个简单的，
分钱体系，
而是一个比较完整的，
发展支持体系，
确实,
非法需要用到这些钱，
来去让足球事业，
在全国各个国家，
发展得更好，
那么总的来说，
这些,
就是这130亿美元的去向了，
虽然很多人，
会以为非盈利，
就是不收钱，
但实际上，
非盈利并没有限制，
非法赚钱，
它限制的，
只是非法，
如何分钱，
那这些赚来的钱，
会继续回流到这个系统里面，
形成一个循环，
非法越来越赚钱，
就可以投入更多，
进入足球的发展，
举办更大的赛事，
那更多的发展，
更大的赛事，
就会带来更多的人关注，
喜爱足球，
这也就使得，
非法越来越有影响力，
而通常来说，
影响力变大了，
带来的，
已经只是知名度了，
更重要的，
会带来，
越来越大的权力，
而非法，
我们前面说过，
从1904年成立到现在，
已经为122年的历史了，
其实,
早就拥有，
非常大的权力了，
今天世界足球，
很多重要的事想，
最后,
都是,
非法,
说了算，
比如说，
这一届世界盃，
为什么从32支球队，
扩充到了48支球队，
从64场比赛，
扩充到了104场比赛，
这些,
都是非法决定的，
基本上，
所有和非法，
自主举办的赛事，
相关的决定权，
都在非法手上，
不只是世界盃，
还有市局盃，
女族世界盃，
青年世界盃，
等等等等，
同时,
这些赛事的商业化权力，
也都掌握在非法手里，
谁是赞助商，
赞助商，
分几个等级，
转播权，
到底卖给谁，
门票怎么卖，
票价怎么定，
这些我们前面话，
大量时间，
讨论的商业模式，
都是非法制定出来的，
那,
当然,
很多小伙伴会说，
这很正常，
毕竟这些赛事，
都是非法举办的，
各种各样的权力，
在他们手里，
也合理，
没错,
确实合理，
但是,
真正有意思的是，
非法的权力，
并没有，
只停留在，
自己举办的赛事上，
非法在很大程度上，
还影响着，
全球各大联赛，
俱乐部，
跟球员，
比如说，
赛事安排好了，
如果你现在，
正在举行世界盃，
需要让到达，
上一届2022年，
卡塔尔世界盃，
安排在11月份，
到12月份去行，
像是英超，
西甲，德甲，
等欧洲联赛，
都必须要停赛，
所有参加世界盃的球员，
都必须要离开俱乐部，
回到国家队报道，
也就是说，
世界盃不仅影响国家队，
还会直接影响，
俱乐部的赛程，
这就会影响到，
俱乐部的赞助收入，
门票收入，
甚至,
整个联赛的，
再比如说，
球员转会，
很多人会觉得说，
只要上海深华愿意卖，
黄家马德丽愿意买，
双方签合同，
不就结束了吗？
其实不是的，
如果是跨国转会，
就必须要符合，
非法制定的规则，
通过非法的，
国际转会系统，
完成注册，
否则,
即便球员，
已经签了合同，
也不能够，
代表新的，
俱乐部，
正式参加比赛，
可以说，
非法掌握着，
全球职业球员，
流动的法门，
那更别提，
我们前面说到的，
促进全球，
足球发展了，
这些发展资金怎么给，
给谁,
怎么通过，
怎么验收的，
都是非法说的算，
也就是说，
非法不仅决定，
世界盃怎么提，
它在一定程度上，
还决定了，
全球足球，
未来的发展方向，
而如果说，
我们上面，
前面提到了，
这些,
俱乐部球员的转会，
赛事安排，
足球发展，
这些都是行政权，
那非法，
其实还有立法权，
足球比赛的全球统一规则，
也是非法参与制定的，
所有的协会，
俱乐部，
球员,
在不管什么类型的比赛当中，
都必须遵守，
那当然，
这里面有点复杂，
我就不具体去解释这个机制了，
但简单来说，
足球规则，
也就是全球足球规则的更新调整，
非法是有50%的话语权到，
比如说，
像是2019年，
针对于手球规则，
就是如何判断球员，
是不是故意手球，
进行了大幅度的调整，
再比如说，
像是原来是否越位，
是否进球，
都是靠裁判肉眼判断的，
看漏了就是看漏了，
现在引入了摄像技术后，
被允许技术支持裁判的结果，
这些规则，
非法都是有话语权的，
所以,
能制定这些规则，
这不就是立法权吗？
而最后，
非法其实还有司法权，
非法里面是有纪律委员会，
和伦立委员会的，
会针对违反规定的球员，
俱乐部，裁判等等，
进行处罚，
比如说，
像是切尔西的俱乐部，
曾经违规签约了未成年人，
那非法就处罚切尔西，
连续两个周期，
不能注册新的球员，
再比如说，
2014年时,
被乌拉规队的苏亚雷斯，
直接咬了，
意大利队的，
接利尼的肩膀，
最后被判法，
四个月，
禁止参加任何足球相关活动，
禁止参加，
九场国家队的比赛，
那这个，
就是司法权了，
你看啊，
梦德斯丘认为说，
应该要三权分离，
对不对，
行政权，立法权，
跟司法权是要分开的，
但是在非法这个组织当中，
这个三个权利，
是非常高度集中的，
那么问题来了，
一个非领利的组织，
为什么会拥有这么大的权利呢？
这个答案，
还得回到100多年前，
就19世纪末，
现代足球，
从英国迅速地传播到了欧洲，
那么各国呢，
也开始成立自己的足球协会，
国际比赛，
也越来越多了，
但当时，
没有一个统一的管理机构，
不同国家的比赛规则，
求愿资格，
赛事安排，
都缺乏统一的标准，
跨国比赛，
经常会出现争议，
所以1904年，
法国,
比利时，
荷兰瑞士等，
七个国家的足球协会，
就在巴黎共同成立了非法，
希望建立一个，
统一协调国际足球事务的，
这么一个组织，
所以,
最初的非法，
并不是为了赚钱，
也不是为了举办世界杯，
那个时候也没有世界杯，
而是为了统一规则，
协调各国足球协会，
管理国际比赛，
后来,
随着1930年，
第一次世界杯的创办，
以及越来越多国家，
加入非法，
这个原本，
负责制定规则，
协调秩序的组织，
也逐渐拥有了，
今天,
管理世界足球的权利，
那正如我们所说的嘛，
这形成了一个循环，
非法的权利越大，
就越来越赚钱，
就可以投入，
更多的资金，
推动足球的发展，
举办更大赛事，
更多的发展，
更大赛事，
就会带来更多的人，
关注,
喜爱足球，
这也就使得非法，
有更大的影响力，
和权力了，
但是这么大的权力，
就没人能管得住了嘛，
确实有，
但力量有限，
能够最直接影响非法的，
其实是组成非法的，
这211个协会会员，
不过,
他们的权力，
主要是集中在，
组织治理，
而不是日常管理，
啥意思，
比如说，
他们可以一个协会，
一票,
选举非法的主席，
一个成员，
去省医院这个财务报告，
修改章程等等，
但是,
世界杯的扩军，
商业合作，
转播权怎么买，
票价怎么定，
这些具体的事务，
并不是211个协会成员，
每天投票决定的，
这一点，
其实很像，
很多国家种代议制，
就普通民众，
可以选总统，
可以选议员，
但不会每天决定，
国家具体怎么管理，
那么这些协会会员，
也是一样的，
他们决定的是，
谁来管理非法，
而不是决定，
非法怎么管理足球，
怎么管理世界杯，
而除了协会会员之外，
各国的司法机关，
其实也会在非常有限的情况下，
介入到非法当中，
比如说，
美国的司法部，
FBI,
如果他们怀疑，
非法的相关人员，
涉嫌商业贿赂，
洗钱这些违法行为，
并且,
按键涉及到，
美国司法管辖，
那就可以展开调查，
甚至发起起诉，
但这里要注意，
他们拥有的，
并不是监管权，
只有当涉嫌违法，
并且掌握相应证据以后，
各国的司法机关，
才能够介入。
所以,
这就是非法的权利版图，
它拥有对世界杯的绝对所有权，
对足球规则的制定权，
对球员和俱乐部的。
间接影响能力，
它还有司法权，
而它的权利边界，
几乎不存在，
但是也正因如此，
当一个组织拥有如此大的权利，
同时又缺乏外部的约束时候，
各种争议和腐败，
也就会开始出现。
这些年，
越来越多跟非法权利相关的负面新闻，
也随之浮出水面。
那么最经典也是影响最大的一次，
就是2015年的非法腐败案。
那么2015年5月份的时候，
就非法官员们在酒店休息的时候，
准备第二天竞选主席，
突然，瑞士警方就闯入了，
逮捕了七名非法高官。
同一天，
美国司法部公布了一份，
47项指控的起诉书，
涉及贿赂欺诈细迁，
而这个起诉的背后，
实际上是跟世界盃的主办权相关。
2010年的时候，
非法宣布2022年的世界盃有卡塔尔主办，
这个决定本身就是充满争议的，
卡塔尔下级气温高达50度，
就根本没有足球的传统。
那么美国司法部的调查显示，
卡塔尔为了获得2022年世界盃的主办权，
向非法官员支付了数百万美元的贿赂。
那么更理谱的是，
一些非法官员，
甚至同时收受多个竞标果的贿赂。
那看谁给的更多，就选谁。
也正是因为这一系列的事件，
非法后来对于世界盃举办权的产生机制进行了改革。
从2016年开始，
世界盃的举办就不再是有少数的非法高层直接决定的，
而是改为有211个协会会员，
共同投票决定。
而说到协会会员，
就又要提到协会会员的权利了。
我们刚刚说了，
这211个协会会员每人一票，
是可以选举非法主席和高层的。
诶，这听起来是挺民主的。
但是别忘了另外一件事情啊，
非法也同时负责向各个协会拨付发展资金，
帮助他们发展本国足球。
那么对于德国法国这些足球强过来说，
这笔钱可能没有那么重要，
但是对于很多足球欠发达的小协会小国家而言，
这些资金的影响力就完全不一样了。
2011年的时候，
非法主席竞选人之一的冰hammon组织了一场竞选会议，
大约有30个协会成员的代表参加。
那么会议结束之后，
工作人员给每位代表发了一个棕色的信封，
里面装着4万美元的现金。
那么所行最终由巴哈马足协代表。
牵头举报了这件事情，
而这个竞选人冰hammon解释说，
这不是买票，
而是提供给这些协会的发展资金。
不过这个解释最终没有被采信，
冰hammon最终被终身禁止从事足球相关的活动，
但也没有因此受到刑事处罚。
所以你看，
谁来当选也是可以操弄的。
而除了在哪举办，谁来当选？
其实谁来赞助，
谁获得转播权，
这些商业合作的权利，
同样可能成为利益输送的对象。
很多小伙伴会说，
谁来赞助，谁来转播，
不是谁出的钱多就谁来吗？
确实,
钱是一方面的考虑，
但并不是唯一的标准，
而整个筛选过程，
本身也并没有完全公开透明。
1990年的时候，
一家叫做ISL的瑞士体育营销公司，
就是非法的一个合作伙伴之一，
但这个合作伙伴不是赞助商的概念，
而是类似于服务外包的概念，
那么ISL就负责部分区域的。
世界盃的转播权的销售和赞助商的撮合。
现在当然，
这些转播权跟销售都是非法自己谈的，
但在那个年代，
非法的商业能力并没有那么强，
所以他会找一个合作商，
会找一个外包的服务商，
来帮他洽谈这些商业化的合作。
那么谁来决定这个服务商呢？
当然是非法的高层了，
而这就是ISL和高层的交易了，
为了拿到服务商的这个合同，
ISL多年之间一共支付了。
4100万瑞士法郎给到非法的高层。
所以你看，
过分的权力，
有缺法监管，
确实会资生腐败。
而如果说前面这些腐败案例，
都是非法高层的个人行为，
那么非法作为一个非盈利组织，
也受到了另外一种争议，
是不是过于商业化了？
尤其是今年的世界备，
很多人会开始讨论，
非法现在是越来越激进的推进。
他的商业化策略，
那这到底还符不符合他。
章程里面的宗旨，
促进足球运动的发展，
以及在全球推广足球。
比如说动态定价好了，
动态定价无一推动了。
线下门票价格商涨，
虽然,
据说,
这一届还是历史上。
上述的利益最高的这么一届，
但是,
越来越贵的门票，
会不会把很多真正热爱足球，
但收入没有那么高的球迷。
挡在了球场外？
毕竟,
在电视上看世界备，
和你清零现场感受世界备，
完全是两回事。
再比如说，
赛事扩军，
世界备扩军，
对于非法来说，
意味着更多的比赛，
更多的门票，
更多的赞助商，
更多的转播收入，
但对于球员来说，
却意味着更多的负担，
很多顶级球员，
一年已经要参加俱乐部的联赛，
欧冠国家的比赛，
等等等等，
而世界备从64场增加到了104场，
这就有可能进一步增加，
球员的伤病风险，
压缩休息时间。
更别说，
非法在2025年，
还同步扩军了市具备。
所以,
国际职业球员工会，
已经开始写信给非法，
要求重新审视赛事的安排，
他们认为，
目前不断增加的比赛数量，
已经危及球员的健康了，
如果问题得不到解决，
不排除，
采取法律行动。
所以,
这些都是权力集中过后，
资深的弊端，
跟争议。
好,
那我们最后，
也再稍微总结一下，
回到我们这一期最开始的问题，
一个非营利组织，
为什么能够创造，
130亿美元的收入？
表面上来看，
答案是，
转播权，
赞助,
闷票,
跟商业开发，
但如果再把镜头，
拉得远一点点，
你会发现，
这些其实都是结果，
真正的原因，
是非法掌握着，
全球足球最重要的资源，
也就是权力，
它决定世界杯如何举办，
商业体系如何运转，
足球如何发展，
也正是因为如此，
它才能把一届世界杯，
变成全球最大的体育IP。
但权力本身，
可能不是问题，
真正的问题是，
当一个组织拥有，
如此它的权力之后，
如何保证，
这些权力，
被公平，
透明地使用。
对于非法来说，
这也或许是，
未来几十年，
都必须要面对的挑战。
好,
那么以上，
就是,
今天全部的内容了。
如果,
有内容感兴趣的听友们，
欢迎留言，
欢迎一起讨论。
如果,
想加入我们的听友群，
也可以在收納当中，
找到如何家住。
那么,
本期节目，
就到此结束了，
我们下期再见，
拜拜!